hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast strand NGS server or
white clinical bioinformaticians love
strand presented by dr. Radha Krishna
that is your Cora a senior software
engineer at strand Life Sciences I'm
Suzy Valdez of leverage and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and sponsored by strand life
sciences strand is a leading company and
software product development cutting
edge contract research for pharma and
genetic testing to learn more about
strand visits WWE LS com before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
presentation is interactive we want to
hear from you so questions comments can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of our presentation also
you are viewing this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window
click on the icon in the lower right
hand corner of your slide window if you
cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem without further ado
let's turn our attention now to the
presentation presented by dr. Rajesh
Krishna butter Devorah welcome sir
thank you so much today for that
wonderful introduction
welcome everyone or wherever you are in
the world it's morning or if it's smooth
or if it's evening we're used to making
worldwide presentations so this is one
more for us this presentation is about
strategy s server and I'm going to be
talking to you about why clinical
biochemically people who do clinical
genomics log strands so much a little
bit about myself I'm a senior software
engineer at strand Life Sciences I have
a PhD in computational biology from the
University of Texas I got that PhD in
2012 and I've been working on applied
mathematics and bioinformatics and
protein flexibility
you know the Nexus of the several
interdisciplinary views for the past
eleven years and it's trying to actually
work on DNA now next week and today we
will actually be looking at DNA seek in
some detail so I promise clinical
genomics and I'm not going to keep you
waiting so here is a PI of our clinical
genomics lab it may be sufficient
Shankaran and we're going to be slinging
for fish throughout this presentation
and we're going to be seeing him happy
and the question we want to ask is why
exactly is the fish happy right
and you know he's the PI of a clinical
genomics lab so the first thing he has
to do what's the first thing has to but
the first thing that any P I of a
clinical genomics lab would want to
think about building a great team right
and the first one of the first questions
you ask when you're thinking of building
a great team is how many people leave me
and of course that usually depends on
what you're trying to do and we're
talking about clinical genomics here and
for those of you may not be familiar
with it all clinical genomics tries to
do is attempt to detect certain kinds of
genetic diseases
you'll be seeing both these pictures
later on a presentation for now just
remember
that we are trying to detect genetic
disease and so the number of people
you're assembling hugely depends on the
kinds of genetic alleles you want to get
that so in clinical genomics you
typically start with a standard germline
panel and the germline for those of you
are not familiar is just the line of
inheritance starting from your answers
to ancestors and going all the way down
to your self right so it is what you
inherit from your parents and your
grandparents and panels that are based
on germline diseases that is diseases
that you inherit from your parents or
called your mind panels and there are
some standard panels that are germline
one of them is recommended by the ACMG
and contains 25 genes so these 25 genes
are seen to be critical in detecting
germline types of diseases right so this
is a great starting point for a clinical
lab set up right you have 25 genes and
you can detect all these different kinds
of views some of them you may already be
able to see in the slide you can see
breast cancer 1 & 2 for instance there's
several other kind of that this
particular germline panel in the 10th
but this is probably too broad right so
you want to maybe winnow it down and
offer a smaller germline panel for maybe
just pressed in ovarian cancer which is
actually quite prevalent not just in the
United States but also here in India
where strand or life sciences are
primarily based so heritage regrettin
ovarian cancer is actually a huge
problem you know it's a condition with a
lot of sufferers in India so it's
certainly something that you want to be
adding a panel for and that panel is the
more specific that if it has fewer genes
then the original 80 MD panel so you see
that once you're the p.i of a political
genomics lab you
start with something that's recommended
by an organization like the NGA and then
you start to stratify and start to
figure out you know that you need more
panels that target specific degrees and
this is actually very common this
broadens the scope of any clinical
genomics lab so you generally start by
adding something common like special
ovarian cancer and then you add another
thing that's common and other disease
and other genetic disease which is also
germline that's common and maybe that
one is for colorectal cancer and that
comes with its own set of genes or
markers and it comes with its own panel
right this one has only 14 genes as
opposed to 25 we've started with and
pretty soon you start adding these
specific tests and you end up with
several tests right a one for each
family of cancers or each cancer and
this is again very typical of the kind
of broadening of scope and narrowing go
for disease specificity that a clinical
genomics lab has to go through so these
are sort of exemplary of the kinds of
tests that strand offers in his journal
panel and this is also typical of kind
of thing that you do when you start a
clinical genomics lab right and this is
just a big it this is just the beginning
now you have a set of germline tests but
so what is that it are you done remember
you're the PI of a clinical genomics lab
right are you done well you're kind of
far from done right because you start
with the patient and then you go on to
be German aircraft itself which you just
saw and you have to do sequencing for
that test you know DNA sequencing and
then you actually have to do some kind
of NGS where you look at the sequence
data with software and interpretation
and then you actually have a physical
interpretation stage where people have
to additionally understand
the kinds of mutations they're looking
at and whether they actually correspond
to the diseases that are in the test or
whether there is false positives for
instance and then once all that is done
you actually have to report your results
right so those are sort of the broad
stages in you know in clinical genomics
and especially this is sort of the life
cycle of a germ line test and we go back
to the question about what about the
teen now I mean how big is it and where
does it start where is n or the people
doing it okay and here's this a simple
example maybe in the wet lab you have
maybe several people again this depends
on the number of panels or the size of
each panel the kind of expertise you
need but let's just say ballpark seven
and interpretation and reporting anyone
add another ten and you know if you're
the PIO clinical genomics lab there is
something that you definitely do not
want to worry about and what is that you
don't want to worry about the
computational stuff right you just want
the computer stuff that just happen on
its own right you just want maybe you
want to buy a server or something or you
know and somehow offload the work that
you have in the software itself that
really it should be according to you it
should be automatic and you know maybe
you can add a few bioinformaticians
certainly look at you know the output of
the NGS software step and at a fast
server and maybe you just want to forget
about it and is that enough
that's the question have asked again
right you keep having to ask these
questions and you know you have to maybe
come up with answers and sometimes it
takes a long time to call the answers
and this isn't enough either if it were
I wouldn't be asking the question right
and there's a critical step here which
is not easy to imagine but once you
start working on clinical panel it
becomes very easy to see in practice so
let me introduce you to three members of
our team at strand on the left is Sanjay
is from the bioinformatics team on the
right is a per notch is from the
interpretation team and the bottom you
see protocols in software right so these
are team members all have to work on
different aspects of of the particular
germ line test so for instance sons I
might have to ask himself a question how
do I set up this NGS pipeline whereas a
burner from the interpretation team is
asking a quite different question she's
asking if a certain variant is
legitimate and proxy ba doesn't have
anything to do with either of those guys
in a sense and in others in other sense
she's everything to do them but to see
that in the question how can I make
everything easier with a few lines of
code or many lines of code maybe some
scripting so you see that these these
team members are all asking different
questions but they kind of need to work
together they need to collaborate and a
lot of their work a lot of the work of
each of these team members depends on
the work of the other members if you
were going to draw a graph of
dependencies between these teams and
there are different teams are you going
to see that it's kind of a clique and
that's to the people who who studied
some computer science and some graph
theory before right so they're all
heavily interconnected so how do these
team members actually work together how
do we get them to work together on the
same piece of software so if we take a
toy example if you add three more
members and by informatics right we're
asking now the question well we all
remember we also added a server so we're
asking a question is there a server
based India software that supports
dozens of users
clearly at least a dozen in this example
but if you take a practical example with
many panels probably far more than just
one dozen
is there a server-based in here software
that supports dozens of users so they
can collaborate on different aspects of
the same experiment and the answer is
yes there is absolutely there is and
that's called standard yes server and
that's what this talk is about to you
know to make hopefully the viewer
understand what the use of standard you
stand in your server is and what he does
so the first thing that it enables is
what we asked for which is that clients
it's a server client setup so clients
actually collaborate with each other on
the same experiment right so it could be
just a particular individual with a
particular disease that you are trying
to analyze and interpret and it's just
that corresponds to one experiment and
all the different clients are working on
different aspects of that experiment
just if you want it and of course you
have backups
and this is almost a given you know with
standing their server
you know the server setup you want data
backups you just want to make sure that
your data is all safe because this is
data but remember that it's not just any
data patient data so it's very valuable
in many different ways and you also have
web page web base manager excuse me that
ensures that anybody would access with
the login and password can check in on
experiments from anywhere so these are
sort of cheesy main features with span
into your server I'm not going to go
into all the features but these are the
three main features that enable Satish
and his happiness because now he has
turned into the observer so that was as
far as the first part of the talk goes
that's just an introduction to stand in
your server and let's see if we can do
something a little more intricate but
right up the alley of anyone setting up
a clinical pipeline right which is
setting up a clinical pipeline remember
this germ line panels that we saw
earlier remember that germ line for
those of you
not know is the the series of mutations
that you inherit from your parents or
your grandparents or your ancestors the
germline this is a germline panel has 25
genes in it every panel you add has its
own unique characteristics thanks
so for instance this is a 25 gene panel
it has a certain sequencing coverage it
says that it's based off a certain
sequencing technology it has a number of
genes and so on right but every panel
like this has its own set of
characteristics right and every panel
therefore because of its individual
nature requires its own NGS pipeline
with its own parameters and their values
right so a huge huge part and I cannot
overemphasize this is just setting up
these pipelines and it takes a long time
so I say day week month year it never
takes a day it never T it takes a month
often it takes months several months or
even up to a year to just figure out you
know what are the right parameters for
any given panel and this takes a lot of
expertise a lot of time and effort from
various team members and there are no
shortcuts here and to be clear that's
not what I'm saying standing geoserver
can do but what it can do is actually
enable you to set up these pipelines in
a much easier and more intuitive way
right so there's for instance this is a
typical DNA sequence you see on the
right top right hand side it has the
line match it has de line meter that it
calling has a bunch of other stuff too
this is just the basics in your you know
you know you have a duplicate removal
you couldn't have based quality
recalibration you could have bad in
quality recalibration goes on like so
there is something that can make this
process very easy that is a pipeline and
a pipeline in strategy a server looks
exactly as you might expect a pipeline
to look right it's the sequence of
stages that are connected by arrows
right so the first stage is connected to
the second stage second to the third
third to the fourth the logical flow is
evident say and this is just one of the
conveniences the other convenience that
every parameter you see just right there
you can immediately see it it's not a
problem if you want to go ahead and
change the parameter you can if you
don't understand what the parameter
means maybe you don't change it right
I'm just trying to remind some viewers
who may not be aware that this is
actually very painstaking process
because we should remember they're like
12 parameters and it's 15 parameters and
it takes a lot of expertise but it makes
it easier if you just can see everything
especially you know when you have to do
this over and over again multiple times
in order to get things right it makes
sense to expose every parameter like
this and also to be able to add and
remove stages as you please so for
instance here there are these check
boxes that correspond to every stage
that has been chosen you can uncheck
some of these boxes note that you can't
actually uncheck the lining because
without alignment you would have
anything right but you can all be you
can uncheck local realignment you can
uncheck some filter stage you can
rearrange so that one of the filter
stages follows another or can be
interspersed with other stages this
automated process might seem simple to
mostly everyone viewing this but the
automation is critical if you have to
repeat things over and over again and
we've already established that you have
to if you want a set of panels or any of
any size any non-trivial panel that you
want to set up will require you to do
these things again and again so the
whole point of standard gear server is
that you can do this very easily and it
enables you to do this
so what is what is good suckish we
possibly worried about right so if you
have a pipeline so the pipeline itself
we've established the setting up of the
five-ton is easy but what about what's
in the pipeline what goes in it it's a
reason of few things that maybe he's
worried about he's obviously worried
about the accuracy of let's say his man
in the course because usually people are
looking at varied cause right so he's
obviously worried about how accurate his
you know the various stages that lead up
to where in calling us she's also
worried about the speed is worried about
how much storage is consuming on the
server because remember every server has
a limited amount of storage so the less
you can consume the more experiments you
can get off one server right and so on
it's that's pretty clear and then you
also want to be able to verify your data
once you get it it's not just efficient
to say that something is accurate you
also have to be able to visually
sometimes go back and do fixing okay so
these are the four things that you could
potentially be worrying about so let's
just look at them one by one first of
all the accuracy and we have a white
paper out on scanning gears and scanning
the observer the DNA see quite paper
with benchmark we accuracy or variant
calls this is by the way that you see
the entire workflow here on top what we
we we high accuracy numbers here the
high precision integral reach the 99%
and so on our drum a reflective of the
accuracy of each stage in the workflow
if one of these pages was bad and that
would reflect poorly on the final
variant calls item to VCS right since
none of these pages you know it since
every one of these pages is validated
that means that the entire with the
variant calls it that you get at the end
also has very high accuracy that's the
first step the second step is well if
you want more evidence of accuracy our
in-house clinical lab remember the one
that Satish is the PIO at fifty clinical
team members looking at these variants
that are generated from standing via
servers on a daily base
so you have 50 pairs of eyes spending
eight hours a day every day for the past
three years looking at these value so
that's the kind of validation that you
just won't get with most kinds of
software we have an in-house meter of
dog food essentially that's what we're
trying to say and we're also certified
by the College of American Pathologists
we're also certified by the National
Accreditation Board here in India as
well so these aspects are a huge deal of
weight to stand in the airserver and
especially exactly you also have the
speed it's twice as fast as that the
gatk best practices workflow and that
should again come as some consolation to
clinical genomics members of clinical
genomics lab especially there P is the
storage now this is another aspect which
is very important because every time you
run a stage in DNA see which typical
workflows you're actually incurring an
incremental increase in the amount of
data that you store because every every
file every additional file are doubles
essentially what you have the port so it
adds on the same size as you had before
so once this in blue is the the jtk
workflow as you can see after sorting
the size the size learn the space that
you consume on the disk increases
linearly for the gatk workflow we're
also standing here pretty much constant
and this is because we have great data
structures and a logical way of storing
things that reduces dramatically reduces
the amount of storage that you need for
any given workflow and finally
verification so we have a lot of deep
and intuitive visualizations we've
worked on our visualization for a long
time now again in collaboration with the
clinical genomics
we worked long and hard on visualization
so that's one aspect the other aspect is
with the structure and the structure is
exactly what you would expect from a DNA
sequence where alignment is followed by
sorting is followed by some kind of
maybe removal of duplicates or maybe
local realignment and so on so you see
that hierarchy here as you traverse the
list so these aspects actually make
verification much much simpler than they
would otherwise have been if you were
just looking at a file on on a file
system so coming back to our panels so
remember I showed you several germ line
panels and we also have somatic panels
so somatic in sort of the opposite or
the counterpart of germline somatic
disease is one that you did not inherit
from your parents but you acquired over
your lifespan so for instance maybe you
stepped out in pollution or maybe you
were exposed to x-rays or something of
that kind something that occurred to you
that that caused a mutation to occur in
one of the book cells in your body
that's a somatic mutation in the post
word germline mutation between Heretic
so we have somatic panel we also have
rare disease panel and also clinical
exam panel and each of these panels have
some ever sub panels associate with them
and each sub panel has a pipeline
instantaneous server and the pipeline's
are heavily customized not
interchangeable
each pipeline has been worked on for
hundreds of man-hours and each pipeline
has been validated as you saw here at
the cap and the N ABL validation so why
is the fish happy
because as we saw these complex
pipelines they aren't a job they take
years to develop
but standing here server makes it that
much easier to develop so now we look at
part three of this talk and it's going
to go over a day in the life of one of
our bio fermentation and we have several
bioinformaticians here and they're all
looking at various aspects of size
different workforce if we saw I'm each
workforce
tied to some sub panel and each sub
panels like something like germline or
somatic or editing so one common theme
that runs through a lot of the things
that my implementations will have to do
on a daily basis sometimes is to verify
the zygosity of of an index so what does
that even mean what is this i gossiped
ii so all of us have two copies of DNA
that we inherited one from our fathers
and one from our father and the other
from our model so our DNA has two copies
and a mutation can occur on either one
of the two copies or both of them when
it occurs on one copy called the
heterozygous notation and when occurs on
both copies for a homosexual - and some
diseases now coming to diseases so the
whole point of this exercise is to
actually detect genetic disease so if
some diseases are recessive
that means that the person is affected
only if the variant is homozygous so the
zygosity of the variant is on both
copies of the DNA not just on one right
and if there is a recessive disease
sometimes they actually have to go back
and verify that you know that the
particular variant is actually
homozygous heterozygous that means that
person is not affected he's just a
carrier so how do you do this in
standing their server here is an example
of the genome browser view insanity a
server you can see that they're very
details that are being revealed about
this particular read list at this
particular reference location on the
genome right so we are on chromosome one
location about eight hundred thousand
eight hundred sixty thousand or so right
and what we're looking at is a four base
insertion at this location right and if
you just look at this and just maybe
gets a little technical but stay with me
here the this for base insertion in
purple occurs on roughly half the reads
okay so since it occurs in roughly half
the resist this location you might
conclude that it only occurs on one of
the two copy
remember we're trying to figure out
whether this occurs on one or both
coffee but if you actually did
realignment here which is one of the
stages in the DNA sequence flow you
actually see that it's the homozygous
way it so in in some scenario where
realignment actually was not run it can
be run to verify that a particular in
Della's formalization another view of
this is to look at a variant support you
in strain in GA server where you're
looking at the same insertion this is
number two species he pizzas for base
insertion right and this is a variant
support view so the variance support you
give you a few pieces of information the
first one is the cluster IDs there are
two clusters of means here right this is
the for realignment there are two
clusters of reads one that supports the
reference to the read the reference
support is indicated by these minus
signs and one that supports the variant
which is in this case the 4-ways
insertion and what these figures on the
right say is that the first cluster has
seventeen reads and second cluster has
15 so that remember our first assertion
about roughly half the reads supporting
the insertion that's what you're seeing
here but in a much more condensed and
too
understand fashion so 17 out of the 32
steps suppose the reference before
realignment but after the realignment
all of them except for one support the
insertion right so this makes the
zygosity of this particular indle in
fact in this case is it an insertion
much clearer
so that was one application and one
thing that a bioinformatician might
spend some of his time on the other
application of strand airserver
and one that is again very commonly used
is in trying to verify chimeric
structural variants and if you don't
really know what that means that maybe
doesn't matter I'm going to try to
explain it to you this is a portrayal of
retinoblastoma in incent retinoblastoma
is worse form of cancer that invade i it
can either be germline or somatic but we
can look especially at the germline case
because the German case is very
intimidating let us say for instance
remember that the germline is the scenes
of mutations that are accredited from
either your parents or before then and
let us say one of the parents let's say
the dad contain the germline mutations
that cause retinal blastoma in him as a
child and he's worried about whether his
children are prone to it or will get it
right so so he wants to know if he
passed on retinal blastoma through the
germline to his children and this is a
very reasonable question to ask
it's a very reasonable question for
which a genetic genetic test could be
performed right and we also happen to
know that that no blastoma is caused by
these long deletions which are remember
in del sol deletions are insertions and
deletions together make up in Del's and
deletions are just one aspect of leaving
del nexus so these kinetic structural
variants that are responsible for
retinal blastoma are actually caused by
long deletion
and these reflect on the data chimeric
reads so here is an example of that so
this is the elastic genome browser in
strand NGS server and what you mean by
elastic elastic just means that these
long deletions they occur across several
hundreds of bases in this case if you
look at this closely you can see that
this is actually a nine kilo base
deletion so the elastic genome browser
actually enables the concurrent viewing
of distance parts of the genome together
at the same point right so if you wanted
to verify the solution it is simply easy
to just double click on this elastic
genome browser bookmark and you will be
led to this 9,000 9,000 base pair
deletion which happens to occur in the
gene responsible for retinoblastoma
hence confirming that this person with
this genetic code carries retinoblastoma
and will be affected by it in the future
or already is affected by it so so why
is the fish happy and let's just go over
the three or four things that we learned
today
so strand into your server is a
collaborative server client model with
remote storage data backups and
web-based data management it enables the
easy setup of several concurrent
pipelines each with its own set of
parameters and stages these pipelines
are fast they are accurate they are
visual and they are flooville with your
storage and it also contains powerful
interrogation tools for bioinformatics
validation and we saw just a couple in
the previous slides so these are some of
our strand clinical panels and the kinds
of strengths that we need to support
each clinical panel and of course to
some each time
as sub paneling sub panel as a pipeline
in strategy a server
so remember starfish we can't think the
piece but petition not is on the only
part of the story she is the P I of our
lab team but we also have so many
different members that make this
incredibly complex and credibly varied
interdisciplinary field possible this is
just a sampling these are our the
leaders of the bioinformatics team they
serve the bioinformatics team in varying
capacity this is our chief scientific
officer and so on and that we also have
50 people in bioinformatics and
interpretation and remember these are
all looking at various aspects of the
DNA sequence various channels are there
and these are found dr. Chun who is a
founder of the Harry Aaron is also
founder Peru is our chief financial
officer so if you need help setting up a
server compute infrastructure for
especially an NGS platform of any kind
especially a clinical workflow we can
help we have a great sales team and a
great support team we've had nothing but
the best reviews from both of those
teams in the past from our various
customers and we know that if you have
any questions about stranded VA server
you will contact the numbers here thank
you so much for tuning in
I am Radhakrishna on arcade thank you
thank you so much for that informative
presentation dr. better Devorah we want
to get right to the questions from our
audience so here's a reminder to the
audience members as to how to
communicate with us questions can be
submitted via the Q&A button as a lower
left if you're unable to get to your
questions due to time constraints dr.
better to pour out we'll reach out with
you via email so let's take a look at
our first set of questions from our
audience numbers what are the
implications of a server client model
does the model mean that visualisation
and computation are separate perfect
question thank you for that so I'm just
going to go back to the slide over here
oh just excuse me for one second while I
yeah they gave to that slide so this is
just a very simple mock-up of the kinds
of interaction that you can have but
what having strategy a server means is
that exactly as you said
client is separate from compute so the
client can visualize while the
computation is going on somewhere else
right so you have you have a server you
have clients and then you have compute
boats and depending on the number of
compute nodes available to you you can
have several experiments that are
running in the background and those
experiments can go on for as long as
they want to but at the same time each
client is viewing either an experiment
that's already done or they're viewing
something else so that's exactly the
whole point of standing via servers to
separate a computation from
visualization and to separate either of
those things from storage and that's
what standard a server enables
looks like we have another set of great
questions coming in then strand NGS
server support only DNA sequence or are
there other options or other workflows
great question we support not just DNA
seek we also support RNA seek smaller
than a chip seek and made it and let
them think as well so there's several
workflows that you can use in sometimes
we can be using one word for what the
other ones one one so we just spoke of
being a seek in this there are other
workflows as well so please contact us
for more details
thank you for that um here's our next
question
the part about is it God is just I'm
sorry
we got City is interesting could you
explain it again sure die gossipy for
sure let me just navigate to that slide
right so I'm just going to go forward
this i gossiped II really mean once
again you will have it one copy of DNA
from your father and the other from your
mother you have two copies of DNA in
every cell of your of your body okay and
if a mutation occurs it can occur on one
of the copies so maybe the one you
inherited from your dad or can occur on
both copies if it occurs on one copy
it's called a heterozygous mutation
occurs on both copies called a
homozygous attention so for instance you
see here in this read list what's
happening is that this purple mutation
it's a mutation because I mean it's
purple because it's a mutations color
purpose otherwise normal non-mutated
reads the color colored grey so you see
that on top before realignment you
actually have about half the reads on
supporting the mutation which might lead
one to conclude that this is only
occurring on one of the two coffees not
all but if you actually go ahead and do
realignment which you may not may have
neglected to do because maybe you are
not setting up you can set up your
pipeline with realignment in it or for
some other reason but if you actually
went ahead and did realignment you can
actually verify that the zygosity is the
on both copies and it does occur on both
you know so the one you inherit from
your dad and the other one inherits in
them all so this is very important when
it comes to verifying the recessive
diseases which occur on which which
actually will the recessive disease is
one where the person in the circle only
if both copies are mutated so me in the
cases that we need to know whether two
or one copy is you take it that's when
this comes with
it looks like we have time for one more
question
the strand NGS server support based
quality recalibration yes it does thank
you for the question
in fact we have sweepingly seen it in a
slide over here you see that is a stage
called recalibrate based qualities so
yes it does
thank you for that
so Jeff is it closing would you like to
take a time and maybe add some last
comments to your presentation for
everyone dr. Vetter do for us before we
add sure thanks Susie
first of all I just like to thank lab
rooms for enabling this presentation and
we do talk a lot we have a webinars and
so on but this is just another forum and
certs know that opportunity so I just
want to say that so people who are
working on especially cancer I think
it's a very exciting time to just be in
this field and we see you know
especially in developing countries that
we you know the extent to which genetic
disease is penetrated you know
especially India is unknown and clinical
genomics it may be a small step but it
is a step in the right direction and oh
and you know I think it's just a very
humbling time to be part of this this
entire set up and I think strand strand
and here
you know server or otherwise they're
just doing a great job of being part of
this huge huge conversation that began
maybe two decades ago and is ongoing and
needs to penetrate even further if
they're going to make any you know dent
in genetic disease you know standing
standing this I have done you know a
great job so far and it's an honor to be
a part of this team
thank you so much doctor better deployer
for your amazing presentation and think
the audience member for attending this
has been a wonderful presentation we
want to get close here and we want to
thank lab roots and our sponsors strand
Life Sciences for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
until August 2017 keep an eye out for an
email from laborat
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we encourage you to forward
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you again next time bye-bye